- There's Chicago P.D.,
there's Chicago Fire,
but I'm most concerned
with, you guessed it,
Chicago Med, let's get started.
(lively hip-hop music)
(train tracks)
- Doesn't look too bad, all right?
You're gonna be all right.
- Good triage.
- 45 year old male left leg amputation.
- Treatment two.
- Trey Moderman, GCS
three BP of 90 by palp.
- GCS three is the Glasgow Coma Scale,
three is very bad you
need to be intubated,
you're basically in a
life or death situation
at that moment.
- He keeps biting down and
I can't get the blade in.
- Pressure
- You bag him, I'll do CPR.
- If you can't insert a
tube to help someone breathe
the one thing you can do is
you can continue bagging them.
That still oxygenates their airway,
it's obviously not as ideal as
putting an endotracheal tube
in but the most important thing is CPR.
Chest compressions, chest
compressions, chest compressions.
- Almost there it's not time yet.
(grunting)
- Never ideal to do chest
compressions with one arm
like that but I can
understand if he's been doing
chest compressions for 15
minutes, it's really tough
it's tiring to do chest compressions.
I've done chest compressions
for a while and generally
after each round you have
a student or a resident
standing behind you ready to jump in
and start doing the chest compressions.
Cause it's all about at least getting
two inches of compressions
to the chest which can
sometimes break ribs, but
it's all about getting them
enough time to get to the hospital
to hopefully save their life.
- I got it from here man.
- Nope, he's mine.
- Okay who the hell is this guy?
- [Nurse] He says he's a doc.
- All right get off the gurney, Doc.
I'm senior resident in this ER.
- Yeah, well I'm your new trauma fellow.
- Doesn't happen like that.
Trauma fellows don't just
run in, this guy could be
anybody you need to see some ID.
I'm all for the show trying
to set up the stage for
this character, but
people don't just run into
the hospital and say
"I'm the doctor now!".
- [Doctor] Get a BP keep giving him blood.
Send a rainbow of tubes
and and a type and cross.
Get his blood gas and get him to the OR.
- Type and cross again you
try and find out the correct
blood type for now
getting O-negative is fine
but you don't wanna keep
wasting the O-negative blood.
So you wanna do a type and cross.
When he says the rainbow
of tubes that's basically
tubes that are sent off for
a wide variety of tests--
a wide array of tests like
a CBC which is a complete
blood count, BMP or CMP
which is a metabolic panel,
a PT/INR which shows clotting
abilities and clotting times.
- No gag reflex didn't even
need sedation, not good.
- We got another problem,
this woman's pregnant.
- What he's doing there with
the ultrasound is called
a FAST scan, it basically
allows you to see if there's
any internal bleeding going
on especially in the abdomen
cause you can lose a lot
of blood in the abdomen
without even knowing
that you're bleeding into
the abdomen.
But obviously the situation
he's found that this patient
is pregnant which complicates
a situation even more.
- 20 year old male, cystic
fibrosis, complaining of chills,
labored breathing, temp's 98.
- Jamie, that you?
- Hi Maggie.
- Back so soon?
- I missed you guys.
- Cystic fibrosis is a-- it's
a deadly illness unfortunately
and it basically you build up
so much mucus in your airway
because you cannot clear the
mucus out of your airways
efficiently as someone
who is healthy and doesn't
have cystic fibrosis.
So you get very often lung
infections, obstruction in
your airway and most people
live somewhere into their
40's or 50's with the illness
and that's pretty much a
life expectancy with someone
who has cystic fibrosis.
- Mr. Delson I see that you're
using inhaled antibiotics,
Tobramycin, Albuterol. You wear
a vibration jacket at night
and use a humidifier?
- Yeah.
- The vibration jacket actually
helps break up some of that
mucus and allows it to
naturally come out when that
patient coughs.
Very commonly we use something known as
Chest Physical Therapy,
which is almost like clapping
on the chest to help
clear some of the mucus.
Parents of young children
who have cystic fibrosis
are trained in giving their
children this procedure.
- Baby checks out fine.
(relieved gasp)
Healthy heartbeat, amniotic
sac and placenta are intact.
Gina though, I'm afraid,
suffered a traumatic head injury
and so far she's unresponsive.
We need to contact her family,
if you have any information.
- My husband and I are
pretty much her family she--
she's been living with us since before
the embryo was implanted.
- That's such a difficult
situation, I mean to have
someone be a surrogate to carry your baby
and then they are living
with you and they're involved
in this horrible accident and they have
a traumatic brain injury
where they're being
kept alive by machines.
That's gonna be a tough
decision whether or not to keep
her alive using machines so
that the baby can continue
growing and it get to at
least to a stage where
the baby can survive on it's
own following a C section.
Man!
- Jamie I've got your test results back.
I wish they were a
little more encouraging.
You're pancytopenic which means
that your cell counts are low.
You've got a blood Ph of 7.14.
- When your blood Ph is
that low that means you're
trapping carbon dioxide within your body
and you're having
obstruction which comes from
the cystic fibrosis.
That's very dangerous
because when you go into
an acidotic state like
that your enzymes think
your body can't function and you can die.
- I'd like to intubate
you, put you to sleep,
get you on a ventilator.
You're getting fatigued, this
would just allow you to rest
so that the antibiotics can do their job.
- I've been intubated eight
times, I think I'll skip it.
- The purpose of intubating
someone who has such
a strong acidosis is
when you put the tube in
it allows the person to not
work to breathe so heavy
to expel all that carbon dioxide.
The machine basically does it for them,
and again it allows them to
rest, it allows the antibiotics
to do their job and it
improves the Ph quicker than
the person can do themselves.
Very uncomfortable, not a
lot of patients like it.
I've never seen-- and again
I'm not a trauma surgeon,
I'm not an ER doctor but
I haven't seen options
given that frankly to patients.
If a Ph was that low in my
hospital generally we would
strongly advice the patient
to intubate them, but again
I'm not super specialized in this field so
I'm just going off based
off my own experiences.
(beeping)
- Sherri?
- [Sherri] Dr. Halstead.
- You need to blow down her CO2,
take her off the vent and bag her,
give her a dose of Mannitol
and increase her dopamine
drip to 12.
- Right away.
- Doctor?
- Gina's intercranial pressure is rising.
- What happens after an
injury to the brain is
just like any part of the body.
There exist inflammation,
swelling, edema and the
problem with having swelling
inside the cranium is that
the cranium is a skull, it's
meant to keep things from
coming in and protect you
but it also crams the brain
when there's edema and swelling
and it actually damages
the brain further and can be fatal.
So, you try and control it
with medications, you try
and give the patient something
to reduce the swelling
in the brain, there's also some
physical things you can do.
Like elevating the head to
hopefully get some of the
fluid to come down.
But, in reality if the
condition gets worse
you need to do the surgery to
open a piece of the cranium
to allow the brain to swell and
not cause increased pressure
within the brain.
- Intubating Jamie is the
only hope we have of keeping
him alive.
- What's that gonna get him?
A week?
10 days?
- It could be six months, a year, more.
- This goes to the heart of
the issue of patient autonomy.
That they have the right to choose
what happens to their body.
I don't know how old Jamie is,
once you're at the age of 18
or older you have the right to
turn down medical treatments,
you have the right and say
that as long as you understand
the consequences of what
you're doing, you can undergo
or skip any treatment that you want.
Nobody can force treatments upon you.
I understand what the ER
doctor's doing, I also understand
what the psychiatrist is doing.
- As soon as we hear
something we'll let you know.
Rachel?
Rachel can you hear me?
- What's wrong?
What's happening?
- I can't find a pulse.
- Oh my god.
(alarm blares)
- [Woman over PA] Treatment three.
- Well the medical student is
doing the exact right thing.
Call the alert, start doing
chest compressions right away.
- You're not compressing the heart Sarah,
you've gotta go harder.
- But she's so small I don't wanna--
- Harder, do it, let's go!
(ribs cracking)
Come on Sarah, harder!
Hold!
(beeping)
There we go back in sinus, get a BP.
- What happened?
- She arrested, we got her back.
- Can you get an IV?
- Hand me a drill, get an IO line.
- An IO line is an intraosseous line.
In children sometimes it's
difficult to put an IV line
sometimes they need extra
fluids, what we can do is drill
a little needle right-- it
sounds brutal but it's really
not that bad, drill a little
needle directly into the
shinbone and what that allows us to do
is to give extra fluids and
medications to that area.
- I just broke a little girls ribs.
- Reese, you saved the girls life.
- Breaking someones ribs
while doing proper CPR
is par of the course and the
CPR actually saves lives,
the ribs are an unintended
consequence but they're a
side effect of trying to
keep the young girl alive.
- This is Jorge's?
(speaks spanish)
- Yes.
- Inside, I found this.
- Why would you give that
to her in this moment?
That's so unnecessary!
I promise this will not
happen in the hospital.
- What happened with the little girl?
- She had a cardiac contusion,
bruising caused her to arrest.
She's good now, but it was a real scare.
- Sometimes when you have a
direct injury to the heart
that can cause a a contusion
which is just a bruise,
and sometimes that can mess
with the electrical activity
of your heart and cause
it-- cause you to have a
cardiac arrest which means that it just
stops the cardiac rhythm.
Actually this is a common
scenario during baseball games
if someone hits a line
drive and it hits someone
in the infield directly in
the chest, if it hits in the
specific time of the electrical
rhythm you can actually
stop the heart.
- Jorge's brain was without
oxygen for too long.
(speaking spanish)
- We have translators in the
hospital for moments like this.
If you're gonna have a
conversation that's about life
or death you need a translator there.
Your broken Spanish isn't the right way
to communicate with a patient.
- He's 20 years old, without
new lungs he will die.
- (speaking spanish)
- Your fiance,
the man you love--
- (speaking spanish)
- The man who loved you,
can save his life.
- A little unethical here,
they're talking about the
patient's condition to
a non family member,
it's technically breaking
information protocol,
but I don't think they'd
get in trouble for this
I think they're doing the right thing
and that's why a lot of rules
are open to interpretation
and I think here they're
looking out for the best
interest of the patient and
maybe telling his patient
information to somebody else
but in hopes to save his life.
So I think legally this isn't
right but I think morally
and ethically it's the right move.
- Going back to the hospital?
- Yeah.
Wouldn't mind being
there when he wakes up.
- Can I come?
- Sure.
- I appreciate that the doctors
wanna spend their off time
with a patient but you
know, you gotta recharge
your own batteries.
You gotta get the seven
to nine hours of sleep so
you can make the best
decisions for your patients
the following day.
Again, you wanna be
empathetic but you don't wanna
burn out either because then
your future patients will
suffer also so it's a
fine line between being a
good empathetic doctor
and burning yourself out.
(dramatic music)
This is a good show, quality
actors, quality script,
good medical info, showed
some very unique situations
that have inherent drama built into them,
but they were realistic.
Based off this pilot
episode I'm definitely a fan
so thank you for recommending this.
If there's another
medical show you wanna do
drop it down below in the
comment section and don't forget
to subscribe and click
that little bell logo
to make sure you know every
time I'm publishing a new video.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(lively hip hop beat)